هناك
الكثير من المواطنين حول العالم متشائمون
في 20 23 20 24
حسنا لقد اصبح العالم مفتوحا اكثر واصبح
من السهل الوصول لكل مناطقه اضافه الى
السهوله التي اصبح عليها التنقل
والاتصالات كان يفترض بسبب ذلك ان تعمل كل
دول العالم جنبا الى جنب لكننا الان نرى
العكس
التعارضا بين الغرب والشرق بين امريكا
وروسيا والصين انهم يركزون الان على
الاستعداد للحرب لدينا الامم المتحده
لكنها تحت ضغط والسيطره خمس دول لها حق
الفيتو ولا يمكننا الاعتراض على ما تقرره
هناك بسبب سلطه النقد دائما ما تعترض هذه
الدول على ما ترغب القيام به حتى لو كان
جيدا للعالم اجمع
هل يمكن تغيير هذه المعادله معادله خمس
دول التي لها حق الفيتو ومن الذي يستطيع
ان يغيرها وقال بيشون
يتعين علينا ذلك يحصل بنا ان نلغي سلطه
الفيتو لانها تتعارض مع الديمقراطيه فدوله
بمفردها يمكنها تعطيل اكثر من 190 دوله
دفعه واحده هذا كل ما يعنيه الفيتو لذلك
هو غير ديمقراطي ينبغي ان نتخلص منه ومن
هذا النظام غير ديمقراطي ونستبدله بنظام
ديمقراطي يمكن الجمعيه العموميه من ان
تكون لها سلطه التقرير عبر تصويت تتخذ فيه
الغالبيه القرار لكن الان حتى لو اتخذت
مئه وتسعه وتسعون دوله قرارا بالاجماع
فيما بينها فان بامكان دوله تملك الفيتو
ان تعطل اتخاذه
هل العولمه بمفهومها الذي نعرفه تطبق
حاليا
ما رايك فيها هل جاءت بالخير على العالم
ولجات بالشر على العالم ما الذي حصل
لا توجد عولمه حقيقيه لان هناك معاهدات
ثنائيه وثلاثيه واقليميه وايضا هناك فرض
لعقوبات اقتصاديه وتجاريه والسياسيه مثل
ما هو الامر مع روسيا والصين لذلك فان
العولمه لا تجد سبيلا هناك مواجهه بين
الشرق والغرب وهناك عقوبات تمنع المبادلات
من ان تجرى بحريه بين الدول